I just realized I was like oh my God I I
did the whole uh I went to America and
back yeah
I was gonna ask about that which was
yeah how was uh how's the uh Ludwig
chessboxing event good on the scenes
yeah so I I went to America uh for about
a week uh to La actually America it's
L.A it's like barely America it's like a
different American yeah we can now say
that now that we've been okay I know
I've been to a lot of States guys
I tried all the Local Foods and it's all
the same for the most part
um but yeah no so we went to uh La uh
went for a week uh mainly went out to
watch Chris box which Chris did very
well yeah we're gonna get him on uh
sometime soon I'm proud of my boy for
almost throwing the chess part of part
of it no no no no he he he's some I
threw more in the chest than boxing yeah
I think uh like like literally like the
throwing of the punches didn't happen
nearly as much as the throwing of the
chest yeah um he had like was it
Checkmate in two and then he ended up
just like giving away his Queen I was
like yeah how do you do that so
obviously
screaming at my [ __ ] TV yeah so
obviously if you don't know
um yeah uh Chris did chess boxing a lot
of boxing event we've talked about a
bunch so you all probably know but if
you didn't know it was just yeah
Christmas boxing someone in between that
he had chess and he'd been training
about this for months and we were all
very excited for it and I said to Ludwig
and Chris was like Hey if you if I get
front row tickets I'll go out because
then in my mind I was like all right
well I'll figure out I'll find some
other work stuff to do to make it
worthwhile yeah uh and luckily I did uh
but yeah so I did that I did uh the
thanks Miss as well Jackson yeah that
was so much fun that was crazy had to go
after Jack Black which is nerve-wracking
I'm I'm I've I kept keep saying this I'm
like it is nerve-wracking to see Jack
Black kill it and then you're like all
right next up we got who
just seeing him real like he was like
what the [ __ ] oh you're a real person
he's so chill as well of course of
course he is it's like it's like finding
out Keanu Reeves is a nice guy yeah it's
like all right no one no one is
surprised that Jack Black is super chill
and nice yeah he was just like hey dude
everyone in the studio was like doing
their job but you could tell everyone
was trying to like get closer to watch
yeah it was really cool because it was
um it was fun enough it was where we did
our rehearsals for the trash taste tour
was it oh really it was in the exact
same obviously you guys would know this
we did rehearsals before we did our
trash taste tour and the the exact
building that we did it was the same
place as well oh nice um which was crazy
ah that was cool so I got to see a bunch
of the tour staff that we did with so
that was nice oh [ __ ] yeah so that was
really cool again oh did that and that
was a lot of fun Jack's great we had
Jack on the Pod he's just he's so funny
he's so chill good to hang out with him
and that was great uh see Aaron again
nice so that was so much fun did that
that was crazy like a big family reunion
everyone who we've met on this is great
exactly it was past year yeah it was
awesome it was like the highlights like
seeing everyone like the final anime
yeah it felt like when I said bye the
anime ending was about to play like
that's uh so that was fun
um and then uh yeah I was I stayed at
Ludwig's house as well that was good uh
although there's so many noises his cats
and dogs kept moving around and I'm not
used to sleeping with them right so they
would keep like trying to scratch it on
the door or come in it was really sweet
it was nice it was nice yeah I I his cat
is so goddamn cute have you seen Coots
yeah yeah the tiny white one right yeah
like every time I see a pet I'm like I'm
like that's so cute but also [ __ ] you
because I want to piss So Gone damn bad
here man I I couldn't help myself but
anyway it was uh Chris came to LA and I
was really excited to see what Chris
thought about La yeah and it was pretty
much what I thought I'll let Chris come
and tell his thoughts about La I'm sure
he'll go off on one what was it like
behind the scenes of the chess boxing
event yeah so it was uh it was
interesting because obviously I was on I
was staying at Ludwig's house so a lot
of the time much kind of getting just I
was just tagging along to a lot of stuff
whilst I was going to do other stuff and
so
um it seemed like it was kind of all
working nicely and then Ludwig had to
just go from A to B and whatever and so
I was kind of just like hi yeah I'm here
I'll turn up
um and it didn't really start to get
crazy until the weigh-in yeah and that
was that was kind of intense because you
just turn up to this giant 5 000 person
stadium and there's just insane amounts
of stuff and you're like God damn like
this is all being coordinated by well a
streamer essentially like his team his
team's amazing
um
but it was it was just absurd seeing all
that equipment all that gear and it
really felt like oh [ __ ] like I'm I'm
like kind of watching like a like a
serious kind of broadcast almost like
this is I can't imagine it would look
that different
um and the weigh-in was fun
um and oh before that as well I had the
interviews where they I don't know you
saw the videos yeah so they had two
hotel rooms adjacent to each other and
they were both really [ __ ] tiny so
they did the interviews in the hallway
of a hotel room and I was sitting in the
room next door just talking to like
Ludwig or whoever was there just
chatting away while they were getting
interviewed and then they would
constantly go like can you guys shut up
in there we can hear you really easily
so they did the interviews I saw Chris
uh said hi to him like all right you
excited yeah the way in everyone kind of
uh was you could tell that a lot of the
fighters were like not really prepared
to do like the whole I don't know how to
look serious or scary yeah so kind of
like oh
but it was really interesting uh some of
them you could tell they were like yeah
I'm gonna put on a show I'm gonna do it
but yeah dude the the ad was so kind of
like it was like kind of faux tense like
everyone was kind of like we're all
friends right we're gonna punch you the
next time yeah yeah and uh it was just
kind of interesting seeing everyone kind
of like slowly interact with their
groups and kind of not talk and then
some people were like not talking to
other people because they were gonna
fight them and like uh I distinctly
remember that
Chris said hi to his opponent yeah and
uh Chris's coach is insane uh if you
haven't seen any Clips he's like is
there's a video of him basically beating
up a seven foot Korean man and he's like
five ten right and he beats him in
kickboxing like a giant seven foot man
right um it's an insane clip I'm Sean
can play a clip right now it's it's
[ __ ] insane this man's a machine yeah
and he's like full-on like proper
fighter kind of mindset and Chris is
Chris right so uh Chris is talking to
his opponent and then
I'm just standing there watching this
and Nick goes up to Chris he's like all
right Chris now that was the fight no
talking to him now you've got to focus
you're gonna punch that guy don't be
friendly with him
you can see Christian like oh it was
just weird seeing him like go like he's
like you're gonna kill him you can't
talk to him
um but that was the first time we got to
see like Chris's uh opponent really show
up yeah because the point was scary oh
he was pretty
he's a big guy so he wasn't he isn't
like very well trained in boxing he's
done a lot of other martial arts and you
can tell the guy's just been generally
fit yeah his whole life because you look
at a guy like that's the man that's
that's the body of a man who has been
exercising for a long time
it's the same you can see like the
twitch chat as uh I wish I could have
seen the twitch chat I was like I was
like dying laughing so he's not seeing
like a switcher because like you know
Chris has Chris has a lot of fans
everyone's cheering for Chris yeah and
his opponent comes on and everything
right it was just like it was just like
a collectively
oh [ __ ] well can you see this man's pecs
and this man's back muscles you're like
oh [ __ ] and then you realize you're like
oh okay like when you when you see them
both we saw them both like stand up
you're like oh so Chris had been
training six months just to get like
halfway to where this guy was before he
even started yeah it's like that we're
about to witness some murder right so
that's where it was like kind of it's
having a lot of natural Fitness helps so
much Chris was and Chris was just trying
to get rid of his like excess weight
yeah and the way it was like oh this guy
beats Christian length uh an arm arm uh
wingspan uh in height in weight uh Chris
only beats him in age
so maybe that has something I don't know
um and so obviously uh you know Chris
Chris didn't really seem that nervous
though Chris seemed pretty confident
about it I think Chris felt like he had
maybe because uh he'd seen the clip of
his opponent getting knocked out like a
week earlier right right his opponent
got knocked out in one punch a week
earlier right
um and I'm sure could play a bit of that
um so you know I think it was like a bit
worried but also everyone's kind of like
well you know maybe maybe Chris can do
well yeah how is he in the dressing room
beforehand
just kind of Chris just sitting there I
think he was trying to just focus he
wasn't really like talking much he was
just kind of like doing it and then I I
went off to go and go to my seat what
was you doing the thing that Chris does
when he's concentrating where he does
the mouth thing
Saturday
so so um yeah the day of
um so I I knew obviously all the stuff
that was going to happen I knew that the
table was going to come from the sky and
I knew that uh Ludwig was gonna slap uh
have a slap match with xqc at the end
right so the day off it's like 10 A.M
and um like months months prior to this
I told Ludwig I was like hey if you ever
need anything you want me to get slapped
or whatever I'll do it back up so that
morning of the Box saying it's like it's
like 9am we're going over to go and pick
up xqc and uh yeah he's just not there
just straight up not into this house
geez all right fine I'll just I'll just
call doesn't pick up his phone and I'm
like is that normal he's like yeah
that's normal that's normal I'm like wow
okay so so then we just drive to the
venue and just kind of he's like yeah
I'm sure I'm sure he'll uh I'm sure
he'll respond because you know he's
going on at like 7 P.M yeah so he's got
from like 10 till 7 P.M to like all day
yeah all day uh and so we get to the
venue
I get there very early just kind of
because I'm there from like 11 the event
doesn't start till four so I'm just
looking around just doing stuff getting
lunch talking to people
um and then yeah around 3 P.M is when it
kind of starts to get like all right
okay a bit nervous yeah everyone starts
to get a little bit more tense because
everyone realize all right they're gonna
have to actually like go on and put on a
fight and you know Chris was just
getting ready Nick was doing up his like
uh the things that go on your arm yeah
what are they called and then I'm like
all right Chris I'm gonna go get to my
seat good luck and I'll I'll come meet
you before we uh do the walk-in
and uh so I'm sitting I got like front
row tickets it's [ __ ] awesome the
boxing's great you can see everything I
can't see any of the chests though I
can't see it from where I'm sitting and
the screen is like up here right
directly up and every time uh they went
to play chess initially it was broken
like the board was yeah yeah right as
you saw on the live stream so it was
kind of like oh all right so I guess
we'll just kind of we're kind of like
just quiet for like two minutes in the
boxing side we're like yeah it's so good
front row tickets are amazing for boxing
because you you see and hear all the
punches really clearly and dude you can
see their face when they're like
struggling as well it's it's it's a
pretty [ __ ] fun experience as I say
for my sadistic standpoint
so fun look at these look at these
peasants exactly exactly and like the
smashboxing was pretty fun I think it
all went pretty well yeah yeah um and
then yeah I went to go and do the
walking thing for Chris uh I I basically
uh I told Chris before I was like yeah
you should um you should do something
when you go out you should do like some
funny a funny bit or something he was
like what why I was like well because
you know it's like a show like put on a
show why not you know because uh it'll
be clipped everywhere there'll be a lot
of people watching and he's like oh okay
so he comes back a day later he's like
I've got an idea we're gonna throw candy
into the crowd and I was like why
what reason are we doing this so he was
like oh it's Christmas in it I was like
all right fine it's your walk out let's
do it so we go out we have these candy
buckets and I'm just trying to Hype him
up and hype the crowd up right and
whatever we walk out and that was really
fun and I just immediately go to my seat
and I'm watching him and man it was
intense it was it was intense watching
Chris I'm sure you you guys watching
from Amazon oh yeah I was watching from
home yeah yeah it was um the boxing
started and it looked like Chris was not
doing great so I think it was like oh oh
no oh no and then the chess happened
then Chris started winning and we're
like oh my God yes Chris is crushing it
which is literally about to win and then
the boxing happened again we're like all
right just Chris just survive and Chris
wasn't really getting in many punches
right because she's kind of like dodging
and just I I it felt like watching like
you know some take on a Dark Souls boss
yeah he was just like dodging like he
was just like frames
literally he was just like how many
iframes can I get out of this I'm
I'm seeing him like trying to win at the
chest yeah and I mean it's definitely
like it seemed like a he's way more
experienced at least in some form of
Combat Sports right yeah you can tell
because he's constantly going in he
knows his reach and he's playing with it
whereas Chris is a bit more defensive
you're kind of just trying to survive
yeah he's spamming the roll buttons uh
and then yeah he threw massively yeah in
chess yeah and it was like oh okay well
I guess he's lost cause he's not going
to beat him in boxing yeah and he's not
going to beat him in chess now but
somehow his opponent was even [ __ ] at
chess so it all worked out and Chris won
in the end but it was intense it was
like 40 minutes long I was like on the
edge of my seat the entire time oh no so
same here watching that [ __ ] live I was
just like seeing like Chris kind of like
clutch at the end with the chair so I
was just [ __ ] screaming yeah it was
hype it was hype I think Chris was a bit
disappointed that he didn't do better in
boxing I'm sure again he'll he'll talk
about all this stuff when he comes on
congratulations on getting like a big W
you're not throwing Yourself by the way
so yeah so um during the Andrea fight
about the third to last fight yeah
um loudly comes up to me he's like yeah
so uh X hasn't replied to me at all and
it's like it's like five something p.m
yeah and I'm like oh okay
um all right well I guess yeah I'm down
let's do it and so he's like all right
all right cool I was like by the way
please don't try and slap me too hard uh
I I have a blood thing so just don't try
and kill me yeah and so he was like oh
okay uh just let me as hard as you want
uh and I'll reciprocate and I was like
okay cool cool that works that works
nicely
um and then I'm sitting there and I'm
realizing I'm like wait how the [ __ ] am
I going up like how is any of this
working like I don't understand how any
of this is gonna happen like I'm sitting
here like the tech guys don't know I'm
going up so like there's no way like
there's no Graphics or anything like
yeah I'm just sitting there thinking
like what the [ __ ] how does this gonna
work like what do I do what do I like
what do I even like do I do a bit do I
what do I do again it's two hours and
I've been drinking a bunch of beers
before this was free yeah and I was like
[ __ ] yeah I wanna I wanna drink beer and
watch Boxing and so I was like oh [ __ ] I
guess I should stop drinking beer so
stop drinking the beer but then I found
that later all after the fight the
Ludwig started drinking shots before
because he wanted to get ready for it I
was like [ __ ] I should have kept
drinking so like 30 minutes before I'm
about to go up because because the
fights could either be five minutes or
30 right yeah so I was like [ __ ]
myself I'm like [ __ ] I don't know like
when I'm going up because the toast
versus Point grow match started and it
looked like toast was about to lose
immediately and so I was like [ __ ] I'm
about to go out so I started getting
really [ __ ] nervous and uh one of
logic's Team comes to me I'm like I'm
like uh yeah so like what how is this
working like what the [ __ ] do I do and
they were like ah well we'll figure it
out in a sec so the fight ends
before the fight ends Lotto comes over
and he's like okay this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna we're gonna throw
it to you and you're gonna come in and
do whatever you want
to do whatever I want what do you mean
like I'm like give me a
am I the bad guy the good guy
oh and he's like oh just whatever feels
right I'm like oh my God okay fine so
then yeah I'm sitting there and then
watching it and I didn't know when they
were gonna queue right so I'm just kind
of like all right waiting waiting and
they go is there anyone in the audience
who wants to slap Ludwig and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I guess I'll put my hand up there's
this great shot yeah I'll just you just
like casually like yeah yeah my time
finally my time has come so yeah I
thought to myself I was like I want to
make it look as like Suave and Casual as
possible so that when I go up it looks
really like [ __ ] extra and over the
top so I just sat there like yeah okay I
guess I was slapping because I can and
then yeah really surreal Herring [ __ ]
German girl was that Sea Dog Jim is so
[ __ ] cool man Jim is such a nice guy
seems like such a cool dude and uh yeah
then going up and I was like all right
whatever it's just all autopilot I'll
just figure it out we'll just do it and
uh I hope I did a good job I don't know
maybe the audience uh I saw a lot of
nice comments so I'm hoping that I did
it went really well yeah and it was a
good match uh we slapped each other
everyone everyone kept saying that we
were faking our slaps we were too Fair
the last two slabs were pretty hard the
first two were like yeah they were we
were holding back yeah so we also didn't
I was at the mindset of like I'm not
actually trying to injure him I don't
actually want to hurt him like I just
want to make it look hard without
actually injuring him yeah I did give
him a little bit of a bruise on the last
lap that I've got him pretty good with
uh he did ask me to go a lot harder so I
did but I still didn't do like fully 100
but also I don't know I feel like that
you don't need that that's a bit
excessive feeling is that really gonna
add to anything if I give him a
concussion
I don't think it needed to happen but I
think it all worked out and I I got my
belt I didn't choke uh I think uh it was
it was uh you know he definitely wanted
to get the time the clock closer yeah
um at some point so you want to get it
like I think very close he's a master at
stalling for Content yeah um but I think
he accidentally he sorted bit too long I
think he actually tried to win yeah he
might he might say he threw for Content
I think he actually tried to win because
if you watch back you can see him trying
to press the clock again and he just
didn't press it in time but then also we
also broke so many rules like I didn't I
totally forgot you're not allowed to
move a chess piece and then press the
clock with the other hand oh but then
also half of these matches no one
[ __ ] played the chess correctly
anyway so some people would just like
move to peace and didn't didn't even
pass the clock yeah Chris's opponent
they did it a few times yeah um so I was
like yeah got it got my dub got the uh
got the belt oh now I was a happy boy